تجمع عدد من المتظاهرين هنا في محيط
البرلمان الجورجيه في العاصمه
بعد جلسه استثنائيه عقدها البرلمان والغى
خلالها موافقته الاوليه على قانون تصنيف
العملاء الاجانب الذي كان اثار احتجاجات
شعبيه منذ ليل الثلاثاء الماضي يقول
المحتشدون هنا ان مطلبهم الرئيسي تحقق
بالغاء هذا القانون الذي كان من شانه
تقييد حريه الراي
والتعبير
ويعتبرون ايضا ان هذا القانون كان من شانه
ان يعيق انضمام بلادهم الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي وهم يطالبون بمزيد من الخطوات من
اجل تامين انضمام بلادهم الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي يعتقد كثيرون ان لهذه القضيه
ابعاد سياسيه متعلقه بروسيا ومتعلقه
بالحرب في اوكرانيا يتهم هؤلاء الحكومه
والحزب الحاكم بمس انده روسيا والامتناع
عن اتخاذ موقفا واضح من الحرب في اوكرانيا
بينما يقول الحزب الحاكم ان رد الفعل على
القانون الذي الغي كان مبالغا فيه اشاره
الى ان هذا القانون كان ينص على ان اي
منظمه غير حكوميه او وسيله اعلاميه تتلقى
تمويلا او اكثر من 20% من تمويلها من جهات
خارجيه تصنف على انها عميل
اجنبيوس الجزيره العاصمه الجورجيه بيليسي